the U.S is printing a lot of money
because it's running significant
deficits it owes now 30 trillion plus or
something along those lines but the
world doesn't have much of a choice
because where else you're going to put
your your investment or savings the
Eurozone two small uh the Deutsche Mark
the pound
the pad probably doesn't even exist
anymore it's an ugly contest yeah yeah
it's like so so the US looks at it and
it's like hey like what are you gonna do
you know it's like the it's the US
dollar or nothing
um and you make an argument that that's
not quite how it works right that I
think we pay too much tension
to one currency in relationship to
another currency and not enough
attention to the fact that those aren't
the choices it's a choice for
transactions but it's not a choice for
storehold of wealth so if you're holding
European euros and euro-denominated debt
and you're getting a negative interest
rate or thereabouts and the same is true
in Japan and you're not making up with
inflation none of those are good it's a
uh and like in the 30s they all
depreciated they all went down in
relationship to goods and services and
other asset prices
so what you see is all the currencies uh
along those lines are sort of tied to
each other and they're bad storeholds of
wealth and that's why you see moves to
other assets it pays to borrow and uh or
if not borrowed but put your money into
um assets that maintain buying power so
you see it happen in all the different
ways so look at whether what you're
holding in the form of that uh cash
denominated and that'll be a debt
instrument that's how you hold a
currency to in order to have a storehold
of wealth look at its real returns